spider-man is one of the most iconic
superheroes of all times standing
alongside greats like Batman and
Superman whether it's ink on a page or
action on the silver screen
all three are stars of some of the most
beloved stories and comics cartoons and
movies but this is GameSpot so what
about those dating video games
Batman saw huge success in Rocksteady's
Arkham series and Superman
well his games sure have a ring to them
and that's for spider-man
well the Webb heads been in dozens of
games throughout the years some
memorable others not so much
giant lizards and with the upcoming
release of insomniacs spider-man game I
thought I'd swing through memory lane
and cover four decades of our friendly
neighborhood wall crawler to see how
exactly he got to 2018
[Music]
[Music]
let's start in 1982 on the Atari 2600
not only was this the year Spidey would
make his video game debut but it was
also the first game based on any Marvel
Comics character published by Parker
Brothers the 2600 spider-man game asked
players to dawn the red and blue suit
and foil the green Goblin's devilish
plans as is the case for many 2600
titles the gameplay is quite simple as
the webslinger you must scale a building
and defuse bombs the trick however is
that spider-man can't do whatever a
spider can which includes crawling up
the wall instead you can only use webs
to move vertically or diagonally once
you reach the top of the building you'll
find the Green Goblin and his super bomb
which you must diffuse to defeat him
while the game does feature pretty good
renditions of both spider-man and the
Green Goblin it's lacking an actual
combat you don't fight the Green Goblin
trap him in your webs or anything of the
sort to beat him
you just have to avoid him in fact it
would be quite a while before fans would
actually get to throw a punch in a
spider-man video game Spidey's next
digital adventure came in the form of
1984 s quest probe spider-man which was
a text-based game that released on
various home computers developed by
adventure international quest probe was
a trilogy of graphical text adventure
games starring Marvel characters like
the Hulk Human Torch and a thing and
Spider Man gameplay consisted of the
player typing out inputs that they
wanted spider-man to perform there was
even a game plan for the x-men though
adventure international went bankrupt
before it could see the light of day and
that brings us to 1989 the year we could
finally fight a Spider Man The Amazing
Spider Man and Captain America in doctor
dooms revenge released for the commodore
64 and other personal computers it's an
arcade style side-scrolling beat'em up
where you swap between the webhead and
captain america and in addition to
Doctor Doom it's how you fight classic
marvel bodies such as the Hobgoblin
electro and an enraged Hulk who is
actually Mysterio in disguise all along
unfortunately as cool as it may sound
the game was criticized for its on
responsive controls overall slow
gameplay and weak story
[Music]
now before spider-man saw his next
starring role he made a short cameo as a
boss character in the revenge of shinobi
on Sega Genesis in the earliest version
of the game the spider-man looking
character was a shape-shifter who would
transform into a Batman like character
once defeated in later versions Batman
was removed entirely leaving spider-man
as the sole character you'd fight
unfortunately this licensing agreement
was only temporary and actually
prevented the game from re-releasing for
years in fact it wasn't until 2009 that
the Wiis Virtual Console got a version
of the game that swapped Spidey's
classic red for pink the 90s saw
spider-man videogames flourish with over
a dozen releases not counting the
various Capcom fighting games he
appeared in as a playable character in
1990 there were three the first was the
amazing spider-man where spider-man is
tasked with rescuing his beloved Mary
Jane from the shape-shifting Mysterio
the entire game is set at a movie studio
so you'll come across less conventional
Spiderman enemies like robots and
mummies the second game released in 1990
was a gameboy version of the first it's
a basic side-scrolling beat-em-up that
follows a similar story as its PC
counterpart Mysterio has kidnapped Mary
Jane but as you quickly learn he's not
the only one behind her disappearance
you'll also have to fight characters
such as the Hobgoblin Scorpion and venom
1990 was capped off with the amazing
spider-man vs the kingpin which released
on the Sega Master System that year and
later came to the Genesis in 1991 The
Game Gear in 1992 and the Sega CD in
1993 all four versions were
side-scrolling action games the Master
System and Game Gear versions were
nearly identical to each other which
makes sense as the console and handheld
share much of the same hardware now when
spider-man vs the kingpin released on
the Genesis it was a huge hit critics
praised its superior graphics and
faithful recreations of the characters
and universe spider-man could even take
pictures for the Daily Bugle to make
more money for web fluid and
according to developer Randall B rice
the game was owned by more than
two-thirds of Sega Genesis owners the
Sega CD version however brought much
more to the table with faster gameplay
new levels and fully voiced animated
cutscenes Tiger no honey what's up I was
just on my way to the studio to tape
today's episode of secret hospital
thought I'd stop by and get a kiss if
you're not too busy
there's something I'm never too busy for
[Music]
it also featured a more nonlinear format
in collectible comic books
however the photography mechanic was
removed in both the Genesis and Sega CD
versions of the game there are alternate
endings depending on how you beat the
kingpin the Sega CD gets two cutscenes
one in which spider-man beats the
kingpin but fails to save Mary Jane and
another that has both spider-man and
Mary Jane lowered into a pit of acid the
Genesis on the other hand features an
ending where Mary Jane dies and
spider-man is left to mourn of course
you could always just save her in either
version now between the release of the
Genesis and Sega CD versions of
spider-man vs the kingpin we got four
more games
once again developed by Sega spider-man
the video game hit arcades in 1991 and
featured four player beat-em-up action
one player gets to control the webhead
himself while others can choose between
Black Cat Hawkeye and Namor the
Submariner critics gave glowing reviews
Dragon Magazine gave it a 5 out of 5
Sinclair user called it one of the best
superhero games and computer and video
games magazine praised its gameplay and
huge beautifully animated sprites in
1992 a sequel to the amazing spider-man
on Gameboy hit the handheld and a game
called spider-man return of the sinister
six released on the NES and Master
System return of the sinister six is a
pretty straightforward side scroller
though the Master System version is
considerably easier than that on the NES
the Master System featured a reworked
platform jumps items move to more easily
reachable places and bosses that would
not regenerate health and once again The
Game Gear received a version that was
almost identical to the master systems
1992 finished things off with a
snessarev spider-man and the x-men in
arcades revenge the genesis version
released a year later in 1993 but both
versions are very similar side-scrolling
action games the player controls
spider-man who must collect and disarm
all of the bombs in the first level
before moving on and discovering that
the villainous arcade has captured
wolverine storm gambit and Cyclops from
this point forward the player must play
through each character's levels before
facing off against Arcade in a final
battle with spider-man
1993 also saw the end of the Gameboy
trilogy with the amazing spider-man 3
invasion of the spider-slayers it was
another side-scrolling action game that
didn't stray too far from its
predecessors the next few years were
dominated by games that only release on
thus Ness in Genesis first up was 1994
spider-man in venom maximum carnage
which is perhaps the most well known
Spidey game from this era it's a
single-player side-scrolling beat-em-up
that for the first time let you play a
Spider Man's on-again off-again enemy
venom in addition to the red and blue
hero of course you could also summon
various other Marvel heroes with items
found in each level
the game was based on the 14 part run
maximum carnage and features a story
told with art from those comics the
story goes like this
the carnage symbiote hiding within
serial killer Cletus Kasady helps him
escape from prison he teams up with
shriek he escapes and discovers
doppelganger with and well you see
doppelganger is an evil clone of
spider-man that was made during the
infinity war arc and actually you know
what to avoid going down a crazy
comic-book rabbit hole it's easier just
to say spider-man and venom versus
carnage and other villains now while
maximum carnage stayed pretty faithful
to the comic arc of the same name it
wasn't received favorably egm criticized
the graphics and controls calling them
sloppy and mediocre GamePro commented
that all of the Genesis versions
features were nearly identical to the
super Nintendos including the drawbacks
that quote made this only an average
sneaking maximum carnage was followed by
a sequel called venom slash spider-man
separation anxiety which released on
snes's Genesis and PC in 1995 it
introduced two-player co-op and featured
both venom and spider-man going after
carnage once again unfortunately it was
met similarly with a less than positive
critical reception
EGM said it quote isn't much fun while
next generation criticized it for not
being different enough for maximum
carnage next generation also noted that
while the PC port was accurate it lacked
quote the intricacy and depth possible
in a PC game now a japan-only game
called the amazing spider-man lethal
foes also released in 1995 on the Super
Famicom like many games before it it was
a side-scrolling action game that
featured Spidey and many of his classic
villains
however western regions weren't left
empty-handed 1995 also saw spider-man
the animated series hit thus Ness and
Genesis based on the cartoon that
premiered just a year earlier each
console got its own version both for
side-scrolling action games but that's
where the similarities stop each version
has its own unique art style and
animations the Genesis version also had
one fewer level than thus Ness but
regardless of these differences both
games were panned for their animation
sound and gameplay now Spiderman closed
out its 90s video games tint with the
amazing spider-man
and web of fire for the Sega 32x in 1996
it had the unfortunate fate of releasing
after Sega had announced it was dropping
support for the 32x
so this game was largely ignored the
only notable review was by game Pro
which called it's game play decent and
said that it won't disappoint Marvel
fans though it doesn't raise Spidey to
the pantheon of great video game heroes
the 90s weren't kinds of gamers wanting
a quality spider-man adventure it was a
decade of games that left players
wanting for something that accurately
represented the hero and also provided
an engaging experience for the next four
years you could only find spider-man in
those Capcom fighting games I mentioned
earlier the web-swinging hero was
captured quite well in Marvel Super
Heroes Marvel Super Heroes vs. Street
Fighter and the Marvel vs. Capcom games
he swung punched shot webs and like
every Marvel character in those games
called out every move he did as he
performed them in fact due to his
playful and joking manner I could
actually see spider-man saying things
like web ball and maximum spider during
one of his actual fights in the comics
so it doesn't seem too out of character
and while these fighting games are
beloved by many none of them were the
villain packed adventures that fans
longed for thankfully it wouldn't be too
long before spider-man finally got a
game fans could be proud of
JT much like the 90s spider-man games
were not hard to come by in the 2000s
but things did start taking a turn in
the right direction this was a decade
when Activision took over the franchise
and the publishers first shot was handed
over to Neversoft
which is most well-known for the Tony
Hawk series at this point Neversoft was
hot off the heels of Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater and as a matter of fact the that
games engine was used to make spider-man
for the ps1 n64 Dreamcast and PC mode as
I speak a lot nice hour of a ball
last time I checked I was ready the game
story follows spider-man after he's
framed for stealing equipment from a
reformed dr. Otto Octavius who you may
know as Doctor Octopus Eddie Brock tried
to take photographs of the incident but
the imposter spider-man destroyed his
camera before you could make any use of
them enter venom spider-man must clear
his name beating up classic villains
like the Scorpion rhino and the lizard
of course venom plays a pretty big part
as well kidnapping Mary Jane and later
playing the unlikely Ally the venom
marathon continues on the biggest TV in
New York
we're shocked now the whole big sad
thing is a public yourself talk show
business the game featured the vocal
talents of spider-man unlimited stars
Reno Romano and Jennifer Hale in
addition to narration by spider-man
co-creator Stan Lee welcome true
believers and newcomers alike
mitem and co-creator Stanley here once
again we find our hero Peter Parker
better known around the world as the
amazing spider-man in a heap of trouble
this was the first spider-man game to
not only include fully 3d levels and
gameplay but also pre-rendered cutscenes
using the in-game models these cutscenes
appeared on the ps1 Dreamcast and PC
versions while the n64 had comic-book
style freeze frames with less spoken
dialogue this was because of the
consoles technical limitations but
thankfully that version of the game was
no slouch in the gameplay Department
players controlled spider-man as the
infiltrated areas taken over by crooks
symbiotes and other bodies both stealth
and hand-to-hand combat could be
utilized to take on enemies and Spidey's
webs weren't exclusive to tying up
victims you could also shoot impact
webbing to knock out foes create web
gloves to add extra oomph to your
punches and create a cocoon like shield
that explodes taking out anyone nearby
several Marvel characters like daredevil
Punisher and Captain America made cameos
and there were even alternate costumes
based on spider-man's history all of
which you could wear at any point in the
game and best of all critics loved it
GameSpot's own review said it was an
excellent framework on which to base
future spider-man games and an
exceptional game to boots while PC gamer
called it the PC
best superhero game there was also a
gameboy color version of the game though
that one wasn't nearly as popular as for
the console version Neversoft had
finally cracked the code on how to make
an excellent spider-man game that
captured both the characters and their
universe in addition to providing an
excellent gameplay experience
unfortunately however the developer
wouldn't get a second shot with the
growing popularity of the Tony Hawk
series Neversoft devoted its time to
skateboarding spider-man would make an
appearance in Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 2
as a secret playable character but that
was the extent of Neversoft history with
the red and blue hero the sequel was
handed over to Vicarious Visions which
worked on the gameboy color version of
the previous game spider-man to enter
Elektra released exclusively for the
PlayStation in 2001 and was largely
similar to 2000 Spiderman though it did
feature levels set in the New York
streets which were previously clouded by
fog like the previous game it featured a
ton of unlockable costumes in addition
to a create a spider mode that let
players create their own however enter
electro had a smaller variety of enemies
mostly consisting of thugs and robots it
still had its fair share of cameos
though with the game's training mode
featuring x-men characters rogue and
Professor X well spider-man
I see you've decided to take advantage
of beasts offer to train in our
state-of-the-art danger room The Mighty
Thor was also set to make a cameo near
the end of the game but changes made
after the September 11th attacks in New
York removed him entirely references to
the twin towers were removed cutscenes
were altered and the location of the
final battle was changed the final game
still has a reference to Thor however as
The Daily Bugle wrote that the god of
thunder defeated electro and not
spider-man
unfortunately critical reception was a
bit mixed with many critics scoring it
lower than its predecessor GameSpot's
review called it somewhat disappointing
and short that would noted that diehard
web heads will no doubt complete the
game several times to unlock everything
the same year brought a Game Boy Color
sequel called spider-man to the sinister
six that was developed by Taurus games a
Game Boy Advance game called spider-man
Mysterio's Menace was also released and
both games received generally positive
reviews
while spider-man video games and comics
were commonplace during this time the
popular 90s animated series ended in
1998 and 1999 short-lived unlimited
series only lasted 13 episodes
spider-man hadn't exactly been in the
mainstream public consciousness for
quite some time that all changed in 2002
when the first movie and director Sam
Raimi spider-man trilogy hit feeders
these films helped kick off the
superhero movie boom of the 2000s which
eventually led to Marvel launching its
now popular cinematic universe and of
course with great popularity comes great
spider-man merchandising including many
more video games a year prior to the
first movies launch activision acquired
the rights to make video games based on
the film franchise that at the time was
still in production interestingly enough
future Call of Duty developer Treyarch
was also acquired that year however
before the studio would get a crack at
first-person shooters it was tasked with
our friendly neighborhood spider-man
[Music]
alongside the movie another game simply
called spider-man was released it was
based on the movie and featured the
vocal talents of Tobey Maguire and
Willem Dafoe both of whom reprised their
roles so you must be quilt man patted
Pete mr. triple-ply oh I've got it the
cushion it played similarly to the
previous two console based spider-man
games with action set in specific levels
some of the levels take place inside
buildings while others find you swinging
through New York City while it was based
on the movie it did include villains not
featured in the film like the vulture
and Kraven the hunter in fact the
inclusion of non movie villains would
continue in every game based on these
movies 2002 spider-man was generally
well received by critics though one
developer Treyarch was unhappy with an
important aspect of the red and blue
hero that developer was Jaime free strim
and is a longtime spider-man fan the
swing in this first game left him
wanting I sat down for an interview with
free strum and he told me that he felt
spider-man 1 swinging with anemic and
felt more like flying than actual
swinging one big thing was that the webs
didn't actually attached to any
buildings this gave him an idea for
something better
[Music]
his idea was to create a physics-based
system that would allow the player to
swing spider-man as if he was on a
pendulum he went into work after hours
to adjust the game's code and after a
couple weeks of prototyping he showed
his idea to people around Treyarch some
loved it some hated it but free stores
bosses asserted that the studio had to
finish the game and not change direction
mid-swing freestream said he thought
this was fair at the time the higher-ups
at Treyarch were burned by games that
featured key mechanics based on physics
a previous trek game called die by the
sword had physics based sword fighting
and while the controls were difficult to
get a handle on critics praised the
gameplay however its sales weren't great
Treyarch was also turned down for Shaun
Palmer's pro snowboarder as the studio
had pitched a more physics based
approach to the snowboarding gameplay
something free Sturm said was unplayable
at this point the studio wanted to keep
physics at an arm's length now with the
first spider-man movie games good
reviews and sales development moved
forward on the follow up this time free
strim was asked to lead development
however he gave Treyarch and ultimatum
well I kind of hope the company just a
slight bit hostage because I said you
know I only want to be the lead on
spider-man 2 if we get to you know keep
working on the swinging system that I
prototype for spider-man 1 that we
didn't use I don't want the job unless
we can you know give my giving my idea
of hair shake and they said alright and
we made that deal free strim told me
that game development at the time was
big on creating huge design documents
before starting work however he pushed
for a large prototyping period at the
beginning of spider-man 2 with a focus
on creating specific game mechanics that
would lead into a larger game at this
point he still had to prove the physics
based swinging or else turret would
force him to continue forward with what
was established in the first game free
Sturm and his team worked diligently to
make the swinging work he said that at
the time video games were normally
pretty easy to learn and figure out
which made creating a more complicated
swinging system even more difficult
focus groups weren't able to figure it
out in their short 15-minute sessions
which sent Treyarch back to flesh it out
the team ultimately landed on a system
that would let you shoot out a web with
a shoulder button swing with the analog
stick and jump out of it with a
face button and for those wanting a less
involved experience trek implemented an
easy swing mode that only required the
use of a single button frees from stress
that without the help of his colleagues
from animators to coders the swinging
would never have come to fruition in
fact [ __ ] refined the swinging for
almost the entire development period
right up until the discs were pressed
and sent out for launch in addition to
the swinging Traer created a new combat
system it includes an uppercut that
sends enemies into the air with
spider-man following quickly behind to
deliver more punishment it also featured
spidey sense which alerted the player of
an incoming attack giving them enough
time to push a button to perform a quick
dodge and of course after development
finished freestream and his team were
nervous about how the game would be
received however much to their delight
it was met with positive reviews
spider-man 2 launched for ps2 Xbox and
GameCube in 2004 and despite the
repetitive side missions like pizza
delivery critics were in love with how
it made them feel like spider-man hey
Parker
I have pizzas waiting to be delivered to
customers because you weren't here hurry
and deliver these and don't mess things
up you got it mr. Aziz our own review
called it a success for capturing the
sheer thrill of web swinging through a
metropolitan area
even today spider-man 2 is often thought
of by fans and critics alike as the best
spider-man game ever released well at
least on consoles as the PC got its own
version that was considerably dumbed
down and even received a 25 out of 100
from PC gamer
needless to say free stream and his team
were successful with their risky
swinging system with the critical and
commercial success of spider-man 2 truck
was cemented as the spider-man studio
however free strim did not provide
significant work on any forthcoming
trailer games he told me that he became
disenfranchised with working at the
company the founders had been let go his
friends were getting laid off and then
an opportunity to work with Magic the
Gathering crater Richard Garfield came
up that was more than enough for free
strim to pass on developing another
Spiderman game despite his love for the
character next up was 2005 s ultimate
spider-man which continued without free
strim or the swinging system that the
team had worked so hard on this game
took a more cartoony approach with
cel-shaded graphics and
heavy comic-book style the game was
based on the Ultimate Marvel Universe
which featured some changes to the
characters fans had come to know and
love the important parts to know is that
Peter Parker is still spider-man and
Eddie Brock is still venom in fact the
game has players controlled both
spider-man and venom for different parts
of the story and retains the open-world
formula started in spider-man 2
there are even moments where you'll race
the Human Torch as spider-man and fight
Wolverine is venom this ultimate
spider-man received positive reviews
with game spots praising the comic-book
inspired look excellent boss fights and
good voice acting and writing however
our review criticized the race and chase
portions in addition to the small number
of story missions versions for the Game
Boy Advance NDS were also released 2007
brought a close to Sam Raimi's
spider-man movie trilogy and with it
came another licensed game spider-man 3
had big shoes to fill after the very
successful spider-man 2 and it was also
the first time spider-man would appear
on the ps3 and 360 now while it did
retain the core of its predecessor
swinging system there were a few things
missing in fact spider-man 3 swing
mechanics were closer to spider-man twos
easy swing mode only requiring the use
of a single button as opposed to the
multiple button system that free strim
and his team had created unfortunately
as a whole it was not much of a step
forward and is perhaps best remembered
for its unintentionally hilarious
QuickTime events
GameSpot's own review said that at best
it was a step sideways for the
spider-man movie games
[Music]
now with the rising popularity of
Activision's Call of Duty series and
Treyarch fate is one of the franchise's
core developers 2008 marked the year the
studio would make its final spider-man
game web of Shadows released that year
on ps3 xbox 360 Wii PSP ps2 DS and PC
it's once again set in an open world
manhattan and features a plot based
heavily around venom and the symbiote
which has infested New York City this
game's key difference is a morality
system that poses choices throughout the
game the red and blue path versus the
black symbiote path this results in
different story moments based on your
decisions such as teaming up with heroic
characters or more villainous ones some
of the familiar faces you'll come across
include Luke Cage Moon Knight and
Wolverine the latter of which you'll end
up fighting in quite the memorable
battle after he's consumed by a symbiote
despite these good or bad choices you
won't get locked out of playing with
either costume you can switch between
the two whenever you like and each has
their own gameplay differences classic
spider-man favors speed but if you want
to deal in more strength than the black
suit is for you the action is actually
quite similar to pass games in that it's
very combo based the now classic
uppercut into the air returns as well as
a bunch of other new moves web based
attacks lets you close the distance
between you and your opponents while the
black suit also lets you take advantage
of the symbiote tendrils to deal more
damage now it's four actually swinging
through the city web of shadows
abandoned the idea of having your webs
attached to buildings and while you can
unrealistically swing above the game's
skyscrapers critics still praised the
swinging for its great feel
GameSpot review called it tremendously
liberating noting that some of the most
thrilling moments in the game are when
you utilize web of shadows sense of
speed and swing in pursuit of villains
and while web of shadows certainly has
its fans not all of the reviews were
positive as a matter of fact the
reception was quite mixed many outlets
criticized the story shallow morality
system and repetitive nature the ps3 and
360 versions both sit at a Metacritic
average of less than 70 while the ps2
and PSP 2d side-scrolling action was
compared to spider-man games of old but
not in an entirely favorable way now
Treyarch removal from the spider-man
series probably had more to
with Call of Duty's growing popularity
but with five games under the studio's
belt it was about time for a new
developer to take a swing at her red and
blue hero be Knox a studio that was at
the time best known for its port work
took the lead on spider-man shattered
Dimensions which released on Xbox 360
ps3 and pc in 2010 the main concept
behind this game was being able to play
as four different spider-man from four
different dimensions say you praise
punks here comes the spider-man leaving
open worlds behind shattered Dimensions
adopted a level based structure with
unique mechanics for each dimension the
four spider-man were the classic amazing
spider-man spider-man 2099 ultimate
spider-man and spider-man Marv
on top of that each of them was
portrayed by a different voice actor
from spider-man's past Neil Patrick
Harris played amazing spider-man Dan
gills and voiced 2099 Josh Keaton was
ultimate and Christopher Daniel Barnes
took the role of Noir shattered
Dimensions kind of left web-swinging
behind putting a greater focus on
platforming and combat that could be
compared to the God of War series
amazing spider-man is pretty much what
you'd expect from the character at this
point taking on a style similar to a
comic book the 2099 levels put a greater
focus on aerial combat and an
accelerated vision mode which slows down
everything around you the ultimate
sections are similar to amazing
spider-man's though instead of web based
attacks ultimate takes advantage of the
Venom symbiote suit and a rage mode that
temporarily enhances his strength and
last but definitely not least as
spider-man noir which is the most unique
of the four dimensions the action and
platforming found in the other three is
present here as well but they take a
backseat to stealth you need to stick to
the shadows to stay hidden represented
by the entire world turning black and
white the stealth is pretty basic
however as being caught is for the most
part easily rectified by stepping back
into the shadows each level features a
different spider-man villain or
character you'll end up fighting of
course this means that it'll be a
different take on that classic character
depending on which dimension they appear
in that means that while Kraven the
hunter stays true to himself in the
amazing universe Deadpool
appear as his ultimate version and
characters like vulture and Goblin will
be creepier than ever in the noir
universe this new approach to spider-man
seemed to work shattered Dimensions was
met with a positive critical reception
with many critics praising the various
worlds and gameplay styles GamePro even
called the game one of spider-man's best
while the high point for many was the
noir universe GameSpot's review viewed
it a little differently
critic Chris waters said that anyone who
enjoyed last year's Batman Arkham Asylum
is likely to look at noir as a shameless
not so successful imitation of that
games stellar stealth in fact most
superheroes were now in the shadow of
Batman Arkham Asylum which was a
standout character defining game that
defied fans expectations of how good
licensed games could actually be many
fans started to wonder when spider-man
would get his Arkham Asylum
regardless shattered Dimensions was well
received pushing activision to make be
Knox the new spider-man studio in fact
the developer would release a follow-up
to shattered Dimensions the very next
year
[Music]
20:11 spider-man edge of time continued
the conceit of different spider-man
universes but paired the game down to
two amazing spider-man and spider-man
2099 the edge of time featured nearly
identical gameplay but with a more
focused story about changing the past to
affect the future the spider-man voice
actors also got shaken up a bit this
time Josh Keaton played the amazing
version and Christopher Daniel Barnes
voice 2099 in the story a scientist
named Walker Sloan travels back in time
to found a 2099 corporation named
alchemax in the 1970s turning
present-day New York into a bit of a
dystopia amazing spider-man and
spider-man 2099 worked together to undo
these changes
unfortunately edge of time found itself
receiving mixed reviews GameSpot enjoyed
its story but found that while the
spider-man's differing personalities
offered a nice contrast the gameplay was
too similar and too simple to be fun
Game Informer's review called edge of
time a major step back from the formula
that worked 2011 was also the year of
fourth spider-man film by Sam Raimi was
supposed to release however those plans
fell through and it was decided that
Sony's Columbia Pictures would instead
reboot the film series with a brand new
cast and story
Activision continued to own the rights
to develop spider-man video games so
with edge of times poor reception behind
it be Knox refocused with the video game
adaptation of 2012's the amazing
spider-man perhaps trying to recapture
the spirit of the previous movie games
be Knox took its first shot at an
open-world game
to improve spider-man's mobility binocs
implemented a new feature called web
rush which allows you to view the world
around you in first-person and select a
specific destination once your mark is
set the action zooms back to spider-man
as he performs an acrobatic feat to
reach your desired spots in addition to
the new improvements to traversal the
combat was also overhauled taking cues
from Arkham Asylum
spider-man featured a similar system
that allowed players to counter
attacking foes at the press of a button
and as for the story it was set after
the events of the movie it was based on
continuing with the cross-species
experimentation of dr. Curt Connors with
many of spider-man's classic villains
being based on animals it made for an
interesting new take on the character
the plot of the videogame is separate
from that of the actual movies but this
concept was eventually explored in the
movie sequel
now while the critical reception was
generally positive perhaps the biggest
disappointment critics had was at the
open-world in the amazing spider-man
acts has more of a hub with side
activities than what you'd normally find
in an open-world game what I mean by
this is that all of the game's story
missions take you into confined
environments away from what people love
most about these games swinging through
a big open world with an amazing
spider-man movie sequel scheduled for
2014 another licensed game was set to
follow with Phoenix once again in the
developer's seat however this would be
the last activision published spider-man
game in early 2014 Activision and
Marvel's partnership ended eventually
leading to all of Activision's Marvel
games getting pulled from digital stores
that included all of the spider-man
games in addition to some of the other
Marvel titles like Deadpool amidst this
activision confirmed that the amazing
spider-man 2 would still release later
that year the amazing spider-man 2 was
the first game in the series to release
on the current generation of consoles
the ps4 and Xbox one like its prequel
it's also set in an open world but this
time it takes greater advantage of it
the swinging now requires you to attach
to buildings and even features its own
unique system utilizing both triggers as
spider-man's two arms left trigger
shoots a web from his left side while
right shoots it from well his right more
missions now take place within the world
as well and while there are times you do
go in
doors players have more options to
approach certain situations including
stealth prior to launch
Phoenix seemed to be making the right
decisions to improve upon the first game
and deliver a more engaging experience
unfortunately the amazing spider-man 2
didn't stick the landing it was B Knox's
most negatively received spider-man game
receiving a Metacritic average of around
50 out of a hundred as was the case with
almost every spider-man game since the
early 2000s GameSpot's review praised
the movement and web swinging but only
when staying in motion coming to a stop
to grab a collectable or run up a wall
would often have you clip through walls
causing the camera to jitter and shake
Eurogamer criticized its technical shot
eNOS polygon was disappointed by its
poor execution and IGN lamented the
quality of the game's story games radars
review called the game enjoyable but
said it doesn't innovate in any way and
feels like an early previous gen title
at best and thus was the end of
Activision's relationship with
spider-man a characteristic history of
annual releases with its fair share of
ups and downs and with Marvel being
owned by Disney and the uprising of the
proverbial cash cows that our mobile
games not many had confidence in the
company investing in expensive triple-a
console games Enter III 2016
[Music]
despite only being two years since the
last game it felt like spider-man was
finally back and returning to his roots
this time however spider-man would be
published by Sony interactive
entertainment and developed by Insomniac
Games the latter of which is best known
for sunset overdrive and the Ratchet and
Clank games we didn't get to see much
gameplay of the ps4 exclusive though
insomniac confirmed that the trailer was
in-game and running on the basic ps4 not
the pro which had yet to be revealed at
the time when real gameplay was finally
shown fans were blown away
we saw spider-man swinging moving
through the air with ease sneaking
around taking out baddies with web
gadgets punching them into the air
hitting them with stuff in the
environment saving this guy from falling
to his death and so much more
the gameplay reveal closed out with a
closer look at the game's main
antagonist mr. negative a little-known
villain that debuted in 2008 s brand new
day comic book storyline at the time it
was unclear if spider-man would face off
against any of his classic baddies as
mr. negative was the only character in
sight but with time came the reveal of
four of his most iconic villains electro
rhino scorpion and vulture who all
seemed to be working alongside mr.
negative now we're just weeks away from
playing it ourselves it's a brand new
story set in insomniacs own spider-man
universe where our hero is already quite
the experienced crime fighter but not
only are you controlling the webhead in
costume
there's also ample time spent as Peter
Parker in his quieter moments spending
time with family and friends as well as
his job working on science experiments
of course with a huge return to
spider-man I can't forget about the web
swinging it's actually quite similar to
spider-man 2 in that you'll need a
building the r2 trigger and the X button
yes you press our - a web shoots to the
nears building and then you press X to
jump out of your swing before starting
all over again our preview called the
web swinging instantly satisfying but
added that it's wonderful to see that
there's more to the game than just
spider-man's day job spider-man has
grown as video games themselves have
grown he's gone from slowly climbing up
a building and typing in the word punch
to actually punching enemies and
swinging through a virtual Manhattan for
a long time fans were
search of the game that made them truly
feel like a web-swinging hero and when
one of those fans went on to develop a
system that allowed for such an
experience it would set a bar for every
game to follow spider-man to cast the
shadow over the franchise with its open
world and physics based swinging each
subsequent game unable to crawl away
from comparison over the past 14 years
fans have longed for a game to surpass
hits after looking back at spider-man's
history it feels fitting to see such an
ambitious triple-a spider-man game
return to the traditions that fans have
waited years to rediscover how it fares
however well we'll just have to wait and
see until then I'm sure all you true
believers out there have your fingers
crossed for something special
[Music]
are the resist reading aerial acrobats
there before survived I'm not kidding
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just a tournament that's it food pizza
now to get back and return the back
[Music]